- Molly Hawkey here, your
favorite Snapchat life coach.
Awakening the inspiration
within, for free.
Cause I'm not, I can't,
I'm not allowed to charge
because I'm not certified.
But today we turn to
civil rights dude,
Mahatma Gandhi,
best known for his
inspirational quotes,
be the change you wish
to see in the world.
He's huge on Instagram.
Like The Fat Jewish.
What kind of change do I
want to see in the world?
Well for me, I go
straight to my chin.
In high school,
they used to call me
Molly the Chin Hawkey,
and Molly Leno,
and Stupid Molly Hawkey,
the girl who shit her
pants in 7th grade P.E.,
and Molly Sucks,
so stuff like that.
Not anymore though,
cause, here we go.
I'm here with Dr. Jensen.
Doc, I'm full of self love,
and I love most of my face,
but I've always wanted
to change my chin.
What do you think?
- Well it's not a
very common procedure,
the recovery time's
terribly long.
But, I can say that
the results will be
not bad.
- Great, let's do it.
- What?
Okay.
Uh, do you have any objections
to doing this in Mexico?
Got a couple--
- Hey guys, today's the big day.
The bandages are coming off,
and we're gonna unleash
the beauty monster.
Can you help me.
Do you think people can
understand what I'm saying?
(laughs)
I hope they put
my molars back in.
(whimpering)
Wow.
- Wow.
- Now that's the
change I want to see.
- You look good.
- It still hurts when I smile.